des yvelinois au coeur de la campagne
grecque avec leurs partenaires européens
la maison de l'europe des yvelines a
découvert l'île de rhodes entre la mer
egée et la mer méditerranée et notamment
le savoir-faire des habitantes de la
ville d'apollonia on a pu voir l'habitat
traditionnel également les différents
outils utilisés pour tisser mais aussi
tailler le bois presser les olives
récoltées ou obtenir en tout cas du miel
l'île de rhodes le poumon de l'archipel
dodécanèse composée de 160
il est près de 250000 habitants ses
paysages méditerranéens attire près de
2,5 millions de touristes par an à côté
des zones touristiques qui concentrent
beaucoup de touristes on a une culture
agricole très présentes nous avons des
îles isolées des îles - qui ont leurs
propres besoins parce que même une itt
de moins de 50 personnes a besoin d'un
accès à la santé à l'éducation
cela est un challenge pour beaucoup
d'idées face à l' isolement l'île de
tilos développe des panneaux
photovoltaïques et des éoliennes
objectif rendre les habitants autonome
en énergie
on couvre 100% des besoins énergétiques
divers de l'isd est-il aussi on ressent
pour son des besoins énergétiques de
lille pour l'hiver et ont fait un
excellent de 30% pour l'été redistribuer
vers les autres il tout cela pour
réduire les consommations de pétrole de
ce séjour s'inscrit dans le projet riz
dit
une collaboration entre plusieurs
associations de pays européens avec
comme but de partager les expériences
pour développer les zones rurales
prochaine étape au mois de juin en
pologne